be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so as we continue our discussion on DC
rebirth for those of you guys that had a
chance to see my episode of collecting
coffee on Sunday
now we had talked about how with
Hickman's Fantastic Four and with those
various videos being ongoing stories in
the background of my regular videos then
I was kind of experimenting with you
guys
I was looking to see how you guys would
be receptive to having double videos
almost every day and having stories in
the background of our existing content
on you know character discussions and
different things like that and so what I
want to do is I want to start paying a
little more attention to DC simply
because it really didn't make any sense
to change from Marvel explained to
commerce explained if I'm not going to
give DC some due diligence and to be
honest I'm really just now getting
around to reading a lot of the DC
rebirth content but I'm absolutely
loving Batman and so what I want to do
is basically run over this story I guess
the entirety the entire six-part series
Batman
I am Gotham we're going to do one video
over the course of this week or I guess
one issue over the course of this week
so you guys will get the full brunt of
the experience and decide for yourselves
whether or not you know Batman from DC
we birth is something that you're
interested in picking up but I am Gotham
of course is the official start of
Batman rebirth in DC Comics under the
writing of Tom King now one of the big
differences here is in the Batman
rebirth number one issue that was
basically kind of giving us a status quo
and what it was telling us is that Duke
Thomas a character who appeared as part
of Snyder's run on Batman who was the
leader of the vigilante group calling
themselves Robins that he's basically
been taken under the wing of Batman as
the new Robin and so at this point we
basically had several Robins of course
the first was Dick Grayson the second
was Jason Todd the third was I think
Stephanie rum so I was a Carrie Kelley
followed by Stephanie Brown and then I
think we got into Tim Drake but I'm not
going to swear that I'm correct about
that chronology well Duke Thomas comes
to us as the newest Robin and so this
basically gives us a chance to see how
Batman is relating to him now what we do
here is we initially pick up in a flight
now in terms of the people in this
flight they're not extremely important
for this first issue but it does give us
some context right now we basically have
Bruce Wayne and we have Commissioner
Gordon talking to one another
talking about how there was a raid on
Fort Marshall but that somebody had
basically taken off with a handful of
rockets somebody had taken off with with
weapons and the question was what what
are they going to do with them what's
the big plan here but even then they're
not really talking too heavily about it
and so it's just kind of like okay what
what direction are things really going
in here because Tom Kane you're off
sorry Tim King is basically playing the
the very slow road here he's playing the
the very slow game so to speak but in
the middle of their conversation Batman
and Commissioner Gordon witnessed the
plane being blown up after a rocket
seemingly hits it from behind and so
what we do of course we pick up with
Bruce Wayne immediately taking off and
he's talking to do and what he says is
I'm sorry talking to Alfred and what he
says is he needs a plan to basically
figure out what's going on with this
plane and that's the basis for high into
this particular comic this whole first
issue is showing us the lengths that
Batman's goes to and this is one of the
reasons why this is so cool is because
Tom King doesn't leave us hanging Tom
King doesn't suddenly just jump from one
scenario to the other he takes us
through every single step of the way and
so one of the first things he does is
Batman sends out an SOS to the Justice
League specifically to Superman and -
Hal Jordan because it would make sense
to us as the reader that if a plane was
crashing to the ground in Gotham City
that Superman would get there in seconds
in moments he'd be able to save the
plane and everything would be fine if he
wasn't able to do it Hal Jordan might be
able to get there a little bit slower
but he'd get there pretty fast and he'd
be able to use his power ring to save
the plane but what Tom King is basically
telling us here is that or I guess he's
providing an answer to all those
individuals who asked the question if
Batman encountered a scenario where it
seems insurmountable that he can come
out on top why doesn't he contact the
Justice League and the response at
Alfred gives Batman is that nobody in
the Justice League is picking up they're
all busy off doing their own things
they're fighting their own villains or
dealing with their own own individual
problems and they're just not available
to help Batman and so this allows us to
continue on with this line of thought
that Bruce Wayne is going to have to be
the one to save this save this plane and
so what he does is he starts talking to
Duke and this again is really cool
because this is not something that we
see very often with Duke and Batman
conversing what Duke says is that there
is a time frame here that the plane is
I guess that Batman himself will have to
drive in about a hundred 22 miles per
hour that he will have to hit a hit of
ramp so to speak or hit a bridge at a
certain angle and then he'll have to
take off and you'll have to jump from
the the Batmobile and you'll have to
land on top of the plane and so they're
basically just working out exactly how
this is going to happen and again this
is really cool because usually even with
Scotts letters Batman is great as it was
usually he simply just jumps from one
scenario to the other and the extent of
detective work comes in the sense of
Batman analyzing some little detail but
we don't really see them going over the
mathematical angles and all this really
does is show us how smart Bruce Wayne is
the Bruce Wayne isn't simply just a guy
that can put Clues together Bruce Wayne
is a guy who has you know mathematic
probabilities statistics for rattle
around in his head and he's able to
calculate those incredibly fast with the
assistance of Duke and so what we do
here is we pick up with Batman jetting I
guess jetting out of the out of the
Batmobile and landing on top of the
plane and this is actually pretty
awesome because he's talking to
Commissioner Gordon and Commissioner
Gordon again is basically driving under
this plane trying to get to where it's
going to land into the best of
everybody's estimates including Batman
himself that it's going to land in the
the tri-corner yards and Batman's idea
is to keep this from happening and the
reason why is because if it did there
are crowds of people there and the the
loss of life would be insane if they all
died and so what Batman is trying to do
is he's trying to get the plane to land
in the Gulf of Blackgate in a giant body
of water that way the only individuals
who who will be in any real measure of
Jeopardy are those in the plane and of
course the goal of Batman is to mitigate
as much of that as much loss of life as
possible and so from this point it's
really just Batman flying onto the plane
landing on to it attaching you know
different pieces of machinery happening
I guess attaching little jets and so on
and so forth and the goal is to
basically steer the plane in a direction
toward will pass through two buildings
and to effectively guide it even though
it can't be controlled by conventional
means now from where here we transition
to the inside of a plane and this is one
of the reasons why I think this thing is
so cool because with Batman comics we
largely just focus on Bruce Wayne the
only real view that we
get outside of his own perception of
what's going on is usually from a
villain like a villain is watching
events unfold or Commissioner Gordon is
watching events unfold and we see their
perspective but we don't really get the
perspective of average people of your
average joes and so what happens is
really just this guy who's just freaking
out I mean the plane is crashing the
guys you know terrified rightfully so
and he's basically saying like they're
in Gotham City all they have is Batman
you know it'd be better if they landed
in Metropolis because Superman would
have saved them instantly it'd be better
if they landed and you know Coast City
because how Jordan would have saved them
you know or Jessica Cruz or you know any
number of other factors you know Simon
dads for example probably gonna save
them you know but they're in Gotham City
there's a man the Flies are you know
that the glides around is a bat what can
he possibly do because he's just a
regular guy at the same time he thinks
that you know he starts saying things
like maybe they deserve it because
they're they live in a city full of
criminals that have gone absolutely
insane and so this is a really design to
point to some greater picture this isn't
really designed to point to some great
big huge concept of somebody to show
that different people react to
situations differently and this just
kind of gives us a bigger understanding
or a better understanding of how regular
Joe's deal with life and death in the
face of Batman doing what he can to
basically save their lives and so the
result here is that while Batman is
attaching various artifacts what he does
is he starts talking to dude and this is
one of the one of the ways in which the
Batman story really starts to get cool
this is one of the reasons why I think
Tom King is doing such a great job
writing Bruce Wayne's perception begins
to shift away from complete confidence
in the fact that they're going to be
able to save the people on this plane to
the possibility that he might die and
the way that this happens is as Alfred
is talking to Bruce Wayne and as Bruce
Wayne is talking to Alfred what he says
is or I guess what he asks is what his
parents be proud now this is basically
just kind of Bruce Wayne accepting his
fate this is Bruce Wayne accepting the
fact that he may not live here now of
course we we switched to a scenario
whereby somebody is watching or standing
over the body of another individual um
and this person seems to seems to have
been the one to shot the rocket that
shot the plane down and this person is
dead we don't really know who this
individual is that's watching him but
the result is that we switch back to you
know Batman's conversations with Alfred
and Batman's basically kind of getting
his affairs in order you know he tells
Alfred that if he doesn't make it that
on the off chance that he didn't survive
or that some event happened that would
have killed him he prepared a guide so
to speak you know a few words of wisdom
for those individuals who were closest
to him the members of the bat family and
Alfred himself and he instructs Alfred
to pass those those little bits of
information on to those members of the
bat family um but he also says that if
something happens to him that Duke
should go train under the direction of
Dick Grayson just because of the fact
that Dick Grayson is as good of a
teacher as Batman will be now this gives
us precession of how Bruce Wayne views
declaration we've always known that that
Batman view Dick Grayson with the utmost
respect even though they've had their
falling-out you know they've had their
disagreements you know they haven't
always seen eye to eye
he was the first sidekick and he spent
the most time alongside Bruce Wayne as
Robin and over the course of dick
Grayson's life he's even played the role
of Batman you know a time or two and the
result is that he is as good of a Batman
as Bruce Wayne will ever be and this is
really just Bruce Wayne confirming it
and the comics we've seen this before
you know but this is DC rebirth this is
basically you know DC giving us a
perception of what to expect going
forward and so you know Tom King is
effectively telling us it's not as the
with DC rebirth all that history and all
that you know
importance all that you know the
relationship between Batman and Dick
Grayson has just kind of gone away
instead it's just as strong as it ever
was
and so as they are as this plane is
appears to crash into the ground just
before it hits her passion of the water
rather just before it hits the plane is
lifted up from the water and Batman's
initial thought is that it's Clark that
Superman has come to the rescue but
instead he's greeted by two individuals
the man addresses himself as Gotham and
the woman addresses her I guess he tells
Batman this woman is Gotham girl that
this is their city and that they're here
to save it I got to tell you when I got
to the end of this issue I was blown
away I was like oh my god what you know
and and so this is pretty solid so far
if you guys enjoy this supposed to
comment you know drop a drop a like hit
the subscribe button become part of the
rap or let me know what you guys think
about Batman high in Gotham you see
number one so far because I absolutely
dig this I think it's pretty solid
but what happening said we're going to
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]